nacho varga starts off as the one who
knocks
as his intimidating demeanor towards
jimmy and price
makes it clear he means business but
as the show progresses his side hustles
go from a source of pride and income
to something that makes him cower in
fear nacho's business partners soon
become his enemies
as his fathers repeatedly put in danger
both by hector
and gus as you would expect nacho wants
out
and he wants out fast but in his heyday
how much does nacho varga make with his
criminal endeavors
well starting off there are three main
portions in nachos underworld endeavors
first nacho simply works under the
salamancas as a loyal henchman
in the middle he branches out into his
own little businesses
while still working for the salamancas
and finally
he ditches his side businesses and just
works for the salamancas
but of course this is when he runs into
issues with both hector
and gus forcing him to find a way out
looking at his time as a loyal salamanca
henchman
this was where most of his time in the
underworld was spent
to figure out what portion of the total
revenue nacho would get
we'll use the same proportions that we
used in how much the slalo salamanca
make video
in that video we determined that dealers
would get 20
right hand men like nacho would get 10
the mules bringing the product up north
would get 10 percent
the cartel booked 30 percent and the
salamancas would get 30 percent
we also determined that the money would
be shared amongst the salamancas
as they seem to be a tight-knit family
despite their evil doings
however if we were to put the money into
shares there are four main beneficiaries
for the money
which would be hector tuko lalo and the
cousins
lalo and the cousins generally stay
south of the border
so nacho would be paid from what would
technically be hector and tuku's portion
which would be half the pot as a result
nacho would receive 10
of the 50 share for hector and tuko or
in other words he would receive five
percent of the total revenue
one more thing to consider however is
that nacho is not hector and tuko's only
right hand man
of course there's more salamancas like
gonzo
but they're likely picking the salamanca
portion as opposed to the right hand man
portion
the only right hand man we are shown
other than nacho
is the ponytail guy who accompanies
nacho here and there
assuming that nacho and the ponytail guy
were the only right hand men for hector
and tuko
nacho would receive about 2.5 percent of
the total revenue
as for how much revenue the salamancas
are able to pull in
we know that after their operation was
dismantled by mike
hector relied on gus for the product
thus the hector should get five packages
so we'll assume that the salamancas were
routinely pulling in five packages per
shipment
given that gus was able to give don
laudio 1.8 million dollars per month
with 12 package shipments the salamancas
would be able to give don laudio 750 000
per month with the cartel share being 30
of the revenue
the total revenue generated by the
salamancas would be 2.5
million dollars per month as a result
nacho's two and a half percent share
would come out to 62
500 a month accounting for any ups and
downs as well as any other unknown
henchmen
will say nacho averages about 50 grand a
month this amount seems quite reasonable
as it's not boss or cook type money but
it's still a good amount making it worth
not to his time
at least at the beginning as for how
long he worked with the salamancas
in season 4 episode 8 we are shown a
fake id
nacho has made for him and his father
for if they need to run away
and the date of birth on the id says
december 9th 1971
of course this isn't necessarily his
actual birthday
but his actual birthday is likely in the
same ballpark in the early 1970s
so when better call saul begins he just
turned 30.
from the very beginning of better call
saul tuko
is very trusting of nacho and even
listens to his advice to let jimmy go
so it's likely that nacho and tuko have
been business partners for quite a long
time
as in several years nacho most likely
didn't get into the business
till after he was an adult so by the end
of season 5 which ends in june of 2004
nacho has been working with the
salamancas for a maximum of 14 years
and given tuko's trust nacho has
probably been around for at least
five years as a result nacho is likely
to work with the salamancas for five to
fourteen years
estimating in the middle he has worked
with them for upwards of ten years
calling it nine years at 50k a month
nacho would have earned 5.4 million
dollars from the salamancas considering
this i'm not exactly sure why nacho
decided to branch out into his own
business
exponentially increasing its risk but i
guess
when you're in you're in so you might as
well take full advantage of the game
however this only lasts a short period
of time before price gets the hummer
and nacho has bigger shoes to deal with
we are only shown two dealings between
price and nacho before price gets the
hummer
however more likely took place behind
the scenes
the first deal takes place in season 1
episode 9
so around june and the last deal occurs
in season 2
episode 1 around july 2002 so
they had about a month of dealings if
they made a deal once a week
they could have completed right at 4
deals price gives nacho 10 sets of pills
each deal
but we don't exactly know how much
product these pills will produce
however it's likely not that much in
breaking bad
tuko was impressed when waltr simply
produced 4 pounds per week
so it's likely that nacho also has
similar standards
if nacho was also able to produce 4
pounds per week at 1700
per ounce he would have generated a
total of 435
200 in one month worth of deals
at this point he would have to pay the
same 20 percent to dealers
and 10 to his right hand men however
nacho wouldn't have to deal with any
meals as he doesn't have any
cross-border shippings
like gus or the salamancas assuming that
goes to price and 20 goes to the cooks
nacho would be left with 40
or about 175 000 pushing his total
earnings up to 5.575 million dollars
moving away from his blue dealings nacho
also has a track record of robberies
for instance he was planning to rob the
kettlemans and he actually ends up
robbing price
plus he diffuses price's security system
with ease
so it's likely that he's quite
experienced in this field
and that rob raises a recurring stream
of income for him though recurring his
robberies are likely not too regular
maybe a couple times per year we'll call
it four times a year or once every three
months
his regular clients are likely not as
wealthy as a kettleman's
so we'll say he gets 50 to 100 grand per
robbery
at an average 75k per robbery this would
provide nacho with three hundred
thousand dollars per year
however he likely gets help for his
robberies so if he pays his henchman
twenty percent of the revenue
he would be able to keep two hundred
forty thousand dollars per year at the
end of the day
this was likely a later development and
he likely didn't get into it till after
working with tuko for a few years
so we'll say that this business was only
up for five years
at that rate nacho would profit 1.2
million from the robberies
putting him at 6.775 million dollars
and finally as for the job at his
father's shop
though he often works here i don't think
he necessarily gets a straight-up
paycheck for his work
this is more of something he will
eventually own to inheritance
rather than get monthly checks from so
we'll say he doesn't get any income from
this
as a result nacho likely made between
six to seven
million dollars from all of his
adventures in the criminal underworld
so it's no wonder he's able to afford a
nice house
but at the end of the day he's
constantly fearing for his life and
regretting previous decisions
so he probably should have just followed
in the footsteps of papa nacho
he could have likely afforded the house
anyways as it's quite affordable at 436
but that's just what i think what do you
guys think nachos should have done
also if you guys like the depth of this
analysis then make sure to drop a like
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one